I'm Laura Ingram this is the Ingram
angle from Washington tonight thanks for
joining us we have a Fox News Alert an
Orlando journalist while already on the
scene of a shooting is dead tonight
after a crazed gunman went on a shooting
spree we're going to have all the
details from Orlando for you in just a
few moments but first no show and tell
that's the focus of tonight's angle
[Music]
all right they say that 90 of success in
life is just showing up well success is
what the B-2 bombers Biden and blinken
are hoping for with their recent trips
to Ukraine and Eastern Europe
Biden's presence there when he wasn't
tripping upstairs was meant to bolster
and reassure the people of the region
funding a proxy war against Russia with
tens of billions of dollars in U.S Aid
that's one thing but by actually showing
up there he wanted the world to know
that he's making a personal commitment
to Ukraine
our commitment is to the people of
Ukraine
and the future of Ukraine there should
be no doubt or support you for Ukraine
will not waver America stands with you
and the world stands with you
Keith has captured a part of my heart I
must say
well Biden and his Entourage showed up
in Ukraine and then in Poland because
again they want everyone to know they're
going to do whatever it takes
and they relish the role of being
Europe's protector
but what about being America's protector
once in a while
does he care about playing that role not
so much
their policies in the bind
Administration have made our families
poorer and our streets more dangerous
inflation we know it's still eating into
savings and retirement accounts
and when a crisis happens right here at
home
that they find kind of politically
inconvenient well they just don't show
up
do you have any plans to visit the
Border
I'm here in Guatemala today at some
point you know I
we are going to The Border we've been to
the Border you haven't been to the
Border
I and I haven't been to Europe and I
mean I don't I don't understand the
point that you're making
and then when they finally do show up
it's all carefully choreographed and far
away from those inconvenient truths
President Biden did not appear to meet
or actually see any migrants there
including as he visited a migrant Aid
Center so everyone asked the White House
why that was the White House says well
there were no migrants there at the time
that's your reporting Rosa that those
migrants were there the president didn't
interact with any of them
no he did not
well even the best laid plans do fall
apart
border patrol agents confronting their
boss in Texas during a visit by Homeland
Security secretary Alejandra mayorkas he
was in the room when border patrol Chief
Raul Ortiz met with agents who told him
morale is at an all-time low
heck their failure to show up and solve
the problem at the border it's so
damaging now that illegals are even
coming across our northern border
all right have you seen how cold it is
in Montana and The Dakotas tonight
yeah they're still coming across
well first and foremost our president
members of his cabinet are supposed to
be there to protect our interests our
borders our economy
but to Be an Effective protector you
actually have to really love what you're
protecting and you have to be competent
and yes you have to show up
which is why Biden's absence in Ohio
does speak volumes
they don't really love the America that
that tight-knit community of little East
Palestine Ohio represents
they're working class they're mostly
white they're more traditional
not a lot of diversity equity and
inclusion there
remember Biden's the same guy who just a
week ago accused Americans of still
wanting to Lynch African Americans
to have a figurehead president whose
senior staff Lowe's at least half the
country
my friends that is an American Tragedy
and if he's given a second term
they're going to spend more time
worrying about what they can do for the
rest of the world
and not a lot of time pretending to care
about what happens here
so this prep represents a huge
opportunity for Republicans who aren't
represented frankly in Biden's new world
order at all
it also presents a massive opening for
2024 candidates who choose America over
globalism
of course Trump he gets all this better
than almost anyone and he showed up
we're here today in East Palestine to
show our love and support for our fellow
Americans and this hour of need to the
people of East Palestine and to the
nearby communities in Ohio and
Pennsylvania
we have told you loud and clear you are
not forgotten everybody enjoy your
and knowing full well how bad this all
looks for Biden the media's only
recourse was to try to ridicule the guy
who was actually there to boost morale
today Trump visited the scene of the
disaster that he helped create I don't
know if Donald Trump uh would have made
this trip if it weren't in as friendly
uh Trump territory I mean this was uh
the way Trump likes it the other thing I
want to just point out here that
advisors had tried to accomplish and
hope to accomplish was to make Trump
look presidential
well it's kind of snarky right but it
falls flat it falls flat when people are
hurting and scared
Americans aren't blind they see that
Biden and frankly many Senate
Republicans are happy to give a blank
check to Ukraine even as they drag their
feet about a disaster unfolding right
here at home
this situation kind of reminds me of
that old commercial
very best
the Hallmark
well three weeks after the derailment
they finally sent a Cabinet member uh
was he the best
you don't have a message for them I do
and I shared it with the Press many
times today I'd refer you to those
comments would you mind sharing it with
us no I'm going to refer you to the
comments that I made to the Press
because uh right now I'm taking some
personal time
personal time is it still paternity
leave
again if he's the very best if he's our
Hallmark then I really pity the people
of East Palestine even more
he's going there tomorrow
now if Republicans run on addressing
America's crises before intervening to
address those of other nations
then Biden's dream of a second term
may start looking like this
and that's the angle hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else